when the surf is up but the water
temperature is down a neoprene wetsuit
is a practical swimwear choice even when
wet it keeps the body warm wetsuits fit
like a second skin so many surfers and
divers have theirs custom-made the
tailor measures the client from the neck
to the ankles the suit allows a small
amount of water to seep between it and
the skin body heat warms the water
insulating the swimmer using the
measurements a team cuts out cardboard
patterns then a worker uses the patterns
to cut the neoprene pieces they use
neoprene because it's cellular structure
is a good insulator the number of pieces
in each suit varies according to the
style and size each suit has at least 15
pieces and can have as much as 30 fabric
for the wetsuits comes in a variety of
colors some fabric will be used for
accent panels while others create the
structural elements the pieces fit
together like a jigsaw puzzle
a worker heats one of the panels with a
hot press this slightly expands the
neoprene he places a decal of the
company logo on the panel he lowers the
press again to fuse the logo to the
panel as the neoprene cools it shrinks
to its original size making the
lettering less likely to crack next a
worker applies waterproof rubberized
glue to the edges of the neoprene panels
this is one of the most important parts
of the wetsuits construction too little
glue could affect both the adhesion of
the panels and the waterproofing of the
seams but if he applies too much glue it
could bleed into the colored panels he
pushes the glued panels together at the
seams the panels adhere instantly and
the wetsuit comes together quickly it
takes him about 45 minutes to put a
wetsuit together
he inserts paper in the bottom half of
the wetsuit this prevents the front of
the suit from sticking to the back as he
joins the top assembly to the bottom he
lets the glue dry for a few minutes then
a seamstress turns the suit inside out
and stitches the scenes she uses a
curved needle so it doesn't go all the
way through the fabric this is called
blind stitching it doesn't puncture the
fabric it also creates flat seams using
a hot roller she applies nylon tape to
the back of the scenes for extra
waterproofing a nozzle blows hot air to
melt the adhesive onto the fabric she
sews a plastic zipper onto the back of
the wetsuit and attaches a hook and loop
stopper to prevent unzipping another
team member brushes rubberized glue
around the zipper he presses the edges
of a neoprene panel to the glued area
creating a waterproof barrier around the
zipper he trims the end of the panel
this custom neoprene wetsuit is complete
from start to finish the process takes
five to six hours he tests the zipper
and closely scrutinizes the workmanship
after passing an initial inspection this
wetsuit is ready for a fitting a good
fit is crucial to its performance
if the wetsuit doesn't fit properly cold
water will pass through it and the suit
will fail to keep the surfer warm it
meets expectations so she's ready to
test the water with this custom neoprene
wetsuit